j'accueille aujourd'hui j'atteins
souvenez où jade un artiste aux
multiples talents il est acteur
producteur et chanteur
pour ceux qui suivent la télé québécoise
ils vont le voir dans la série alerte il
a déjà joué dans la série
shadow interne qui est passé sur netflix
mais aujourd'hui on parle avec junte
alors que la sortie de son single
s'appelle fmf bienvenue à toi jacques
merci s'inverser comme pépé rebondit
bien de crissier de parler de ça avec
plaisir alors dites-moi jade c'est quoi
un projet et fait naître cette chanson
qui est aujourd'hui qui est sorti à la
radio mais je sais qu'il ya quelques
jours avec des gens sortis faut le voir
sur instagram reconnaissent connaissions
un petit extrait ils sont à plus de 300
milles donc parlez nous de ce fait mal
au kef mrc de bellechasse et c'est ma
première chanson en français donc j'ai
commencé la musique
il ya peut-être deux ans vraiment genre
un nom de senghor en anglais c'est parce
que c'est plus du côté anglais parce que
j'ai étudié en anglais ce qui est très
intéressant en fait mais moi je suis
montréalais francophones la base mais
parce que j'ai étudié en anglais ça m'a
mis dans le marché anglais donc ce qui
peut supporter j'ai pu partir travailler
à tous mais pourrait donc j'ai comme sa
sortie la musique ce qui est quelque
chose que j'ai toujours voulu faire et
puis maintenant avec ce nouveau rôle
français ben c'était juste comme le bon
move je dirais de faire et j'ai commencé
à travailler avec nouvelle équipe petite
équipe mais on s'est dit qu'on fait en
france est coiffée par français aly qu
on va être le momentum de la série
française et aussi on avait accès à
l'industrie ma musique en france est
beaucoup plus et ccc
c'est un petit peu plus intimes comme
marcher mais mais mais ces gros site est
alors alors c'est ça puis on s'est dit
on s'est rencontré en studio on a pensé
à écrire ça s'est passé vraiment comme
naturelle boire rapidement la chanson et
j'ai sorti puis on sait je voulais comme
rappeler aux gens de un peu a le feeling
du nightlife qu'on a qu'on a perdu cette
année et a été donnée this ce genre
le moment que les gens ont la connexion
dans un club en ce sens avec des
lumières mais aussi tu es c'est plus
profond que ça la vie éphémère elle même
qui la musique pour moi c'est une façon
de créer une gens de l'existence
éternelle donc c'est ça je vais juste
faire danser les gens et leur rappeler
du fan de la vie et qu'on a peut-être
oublié un peu ces jours ci c'est vrai
qu'encore que quelqu'un les joyeuses
quand même c'est une ambiance de club
tout ça qu'est-ce que vous êtes inspiré
de la mythologie pour ce texte comment
ça s'est passé ce lien avec la mito dit
avec qui vous travaillez ce sens c'est
une équipe avec deux personnes le
producteur senior producer et mais wars
qui est une artiste aussi indépendante
et elle aussi a fait la musique anglaise
française et ses radios et une fille on
s'est rencontrés donc selon avis que
c'est une connexion très spontané et
elle est super bonne
à l'écrit des super chansons donc donc
celle avoir dans mon équipe c'est
vraiment quelque chose que je dirais
qu'il ya vraiment élevé mais parfois les
lyrics parce que elle veut toujours
poussé pour trouver le mot parfait et
tout puis moi j'arrive avec oui mon
inspiration mythologie et où donc
mais la façon de le faire c'est plus une
façon subliminale
et c'est surtout plus dormait dans les
visuels dans mon vidéoclips et les
choses comme ça mais on essaie de garder
une gens de de fantaisie de mots qui
nous transporte petit peu plus d'une
manière poétique et et wish très inspiré
par la mythologie tous mes potes surtout
par l'histoire en ciel des humains et
des trucs un peu fous je veux élever le
tout genre je veux vraiment vendre des
choses fantastiques d'un tiers donc
c'est le choix des bouches du ray dans
la chanson qui rend la chose parce que
littéralement c'est vraiment une chanson
que je connais quelqu'un sait mais dans
les mots qui sont utilisés les choses
comme ça et surtout surtout dans l'est
les images et dans le vidéo c'est là que
ça va
voilà l'inspiration mythique mais les
occasions d'aller au club dans un
contexte de convives s'est passé pas
évident mais on va quand même l'écouter
et en même temps les gens peuvent voir à
leur dois ce que vous vient votre talent
d'acteur il est quand même vous avez une
présence naturelle
est-ce quelque chose derrière vous fait
des études au cégep et si oui j'ai
étudié en théâtre et après j'ai fait une
formation en télévision mais c'est plus
comme un membership de six mois pour
vraiment pour se concentrer sur la
télévision et le cinéma mais j'ai
commencé à part ça quand j'avais 10 ans
vraiment quand j'étais jeune j'ai comme
compris un petit peu c'est pas comment
mais j'ai compris que je pouvais le
faire ch jeu que j'observais ou des
bidons
il ya eu beaucoup de pression et gens
nous donnaient des me faisait déjà deux
journées carrières et je vous rappelle
je suis allé voir un acteur qui est venu
nous parler il expliquait sa carrière
qu'est ce qui te fait comme ça puis je
m'appelle sorti de là j'étais jeune je
pense que je peux faire
et puis c'est vraiment étrange parce que
tous les adultes moi je savais que je
pouvais puis je sais pas si je suis vie
je suis ce film j'ai pris toutes les
opportunités que je pouvais être
vraiment pratique et là dedans j'ai fait
toutes les pièces de théâtre à l'école
devant tous pris toutes les opportunités
que j'ai écrit et j'ai développé une
technique talent je sais pas c'est comme
ça juste évolué mais vraiment quand j'ai
fini secondaire je suis arrivé au cégep
ici au québec le cégep comme collège
anna haag a subi une technique en
théâtre acting en anglais le même site à
la clé quand la france est toute ma vie
et là je me rappelle enfin que de ça
c'est l'école comme maintenant je me
sens comme je suis arrivé à l'école ce
c'est l'école que vous aimez c'était
vraiment cool parce que c'est vraiment
concentré avec des cours de mouvements
des cours de voix des cours d'histoire
du théâtre des cours de chant des cours
de création en improvisation avait
tellement de trucs des petites
catégories qui on s'est vraiment
concentré là dessus alors j'ai pu
découvrir ce que jamais et les années
ont passé j'ai continué à faire ça j'ai
travaillé beaucoup gratuitement j'ai
continué je me suis qu'un agent éventuel
manque là ça juste continuer continuer
continuer mais ce qui est intéressant
avec cette série c'est que c'est mon
premier rôle en français de toute ma vie
et c'est là c'est mon plus gros roland
mais c'est drôle parce que l'industrie
française et anglaise à bord est allé
très divisée très séparés des fois ça sa
province mais 6 me suis dit que j'allais
jamais travaillé en france est justement
à cause de ma formation
mais tout d'un coup ils vont trouver
peut-être parce que je suis parti
ailleurs les gens disent ok voici un
acteur arabe c'est des fois des fois je
rentrais pour du team edition tout comme
ça la place à consommer ils m'ont pris
puis je suis vraiment content qu'on va
parce que c'est cool d'être célébré chez
soi dit man vous êtes en train de jouer
ce rôle mais ce qu'on n'avait pas pu
être entendu pour les roms de jeunes
arabes un an
parce que souvent j'ai dit non à des
rôles comme ça qui sont très caricatural
mais la fin c'est que cette industrie en
télévision c'est très s'est basé sur
genre les préjugés préjugés mais
vraiment les catégories de personnes
surtout des fois à ccc la nationalité
des gens etc
mais je me suis toujours dit quand c'est
un rôle clichés les trucs qu'on voit
tout le temps
j'ai toujours dit non j'ai pas dit si
j'ai toujours dit non toujours dit non
turbulent puis quand c'est un rôle que
oui c'est une personne c'est un humain
c'est un gars de montréal mais oui il
est aussi d'origine et là ça devient
intéressant pour moi et là ça me dire ça
me dit quoi puis parce que parce que je
suis
que je suis riche mais au liban mais je
suis parti quand j'étais bébé et j'ai
pas pu justement m'identifier en tant
qu'arabe les sans abri du temps
comprendre que j'étais différent des
autres ici mais alors jamais les six
heures comme affectés dans ma vie mais
j'ai compris très vite que la télévision
et tout ça c'est vraiment catégoriser de
cette manière parce que c'est ça ils ont
besoin d'un personnage né des clichés de
personnages ça existe dans tous les sens
qui c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
donc j'ai vraiment fait attention
j'étais vraiment sélective et c'est cool
parce que ce rôle si oui sonara oui ça
un petit peu partie de des préjugés que
certaines personnes envers les gens
d'ailleurs mais mais c'est pas ça qui
définit le personnage il les montréalais
il a en fait les moitiés québécois dans
l'histoire et et tout ce cliché de
terrorisme sera renversé ont-ils
vraiment intéressante puis je me suis
dit qu il que ça va la peine de faire
celui là parce que j'ai vu c'est parce
que j'étais une personne j'ai vu à
montréal et j'ai vu quelqu'un qui a des
origines mais que ça définit pas le
personnage puisse vraiment ça qu'il faut
faire pour continuer de faire mais c'est
des fois il ya des gens qui prennent des
rôles avons travaillé toute leur vie
pour justement pour jouer
l'arabe ou le latino ou ya vraiment des
choses comme ça des papilles c'est juste
un choix en fait et des gens qui sont
très conscients de ça mais 10g la job il
m'engage toujours pour jouer j'ai pas
l'amérindien puis c'est me font carrière
complète en sachant que oui ok c'est
peut-être pas vraiment open minded mais
que bon travail mais aussi ceux qui
savent pas vraiment où me mettre parce
que souvent j'ai remarqué c'est souvent
du côté français aussi c'est plutôt jean
quand je vois un personnage arabe je
sais qu'il recherchait un marocain pas
mais c'est très très différent de nous
la bible
comme rien à voir comme un peu trop que
c'est vraiment une grosse différence
alors je c'est souvent quand je reste
mario autié sincèrement il va le
marocain comme juste et 100% donc des
fois je me suis baisse sectorielle pour
ses personnages ses pairs me retient à
la base mais c'est dire que j'ai zéro
l'armée marocaine j'ai même pas là comme
d'habitude déjà pas vraiment où me
placer donc je sais que je peux aller je
vais faire l'addition puis et puis mon
prix là là là personnage qu'est ce qui
vous attire le plus que ce que ses
détracteurs au match entre les deux
religieux toujours faire les deux du
futur et c'est le laps et le cinéma
m'ont aidé à arriver à une période de ma
vie que je peux faire
les projets que je veux et j'ai public
ce qui est vraiment vraiment spéciale
je vais continuer à faire du lhb late
éléments et tout parce que j'adore ça
mais ce qui m'allume le plus en ce
moment c'est vraiment la musique c'est
vraiment de chanter de danser mais
surtout parce que c'est vraiment mon
message c'est vraiment mon projet et
c'est quand je fais quand je perds un
rôle souvent c'est l'histoire de
quelqu'un d'autre
je suis un art et un interprète suis je
suis quelqu'un qui va venir dire que
conté l'histoire l'histoire de quelqu'un
d'autre
ce qui est super cool et fun mais
j'adore j'adore jouer cgem met en
musique c'est vraiment moi qui décide
c'est vraiment moi qui c'est bon c'est
bon c'est mon monde c'est moi c'est
votre création
peut-être qu'un jour vous allez vous
allez à travers la caméra aussi à west
et goûté à ça en fait
gg j'étais producteur de séries qu'on a
créé avec des amis qui s'appelle date
m'a dit 'je et on en parlait tout à
l'heure
puis ça c'était 100% indépendant on a on
a levé des fonds on en a mais on a tout
créé puis j'ai joué un peu le rôle de
producteur qui était super cool mais
mais il ya une satisfaction vraiment
vraiment ou qui viennent d'être
producteur est de créer un projet et de
le voir se réaliser comme
là c'est vraiment quelque chose de bien
et oui c'est sûr que dans plusieurs
années
je vais changer un petit peu d'anglais
c'est parce que je veux pas être jeune
pour toujours puis je vais avoir envie
de donner l'opportunité à quelqu'un
d'autre d'aider nos personnes ces deux
de jouer un nouveau rôle c'est toujours
intéressant de changer les choses c'est
des fois je me dis gens ce que je vais
être capable de faire ça pour le reste
de ma vie genre faire des additions
avoir un rôle à jouer le titre c'est
vraiment light même temps c gepa s'est
tu apprends beaucoup de de ma vie mais
je lui met que je me concentre que je
rentre dedans disent que c'est des
situations surtout comme alerte c'est
comme des situations extrêmes ou mois
encore personne j'ai jamais vécu ça mais
faut que je me mette dedans comme
système moi tout le monde leur autour de
moi comme je me fais attaquer toutes des
choses comme ça que je dis que c'est
quand même ça peut être lourd
des fois donc des fois je me questionne
que je me dis est ce que je lis surtout
parce que le processus de télé ce que
les gens voient pas faire des entrevues
des auditions pour montrer aux gens oui
je suis bien pour leur rôle premier - si
c'est vraiment ça aura quelque chose ça
prend ça prend beaucoup aussi
donc c'est pour ça que je suis un peu en
train de me dire pis pour ça que je suis
en train de créer quelque chose d'hors
avec la musique et tout parce que c'est
c'est différent c'est plusieurs actifs
or c'est puis je me parle dans votre
présence à la télévision sur netflix
ce n'est pas juste les séries vous avez
aussi participé à 2020 pourquoi vous ce
choix d'aller vers sa périphérie temps
pour vous investir et oui c'est
tellement important parce que donc gt1
j'étais un juge invité pour un épisode
puisqu'il perd l'un de mes rêves parce
que ses séries préférées ou encore
dragon l'art qui se remontre c'est ça
brise les stéréotypes ça brise les
préjugés c'est vraiment quelque chose
que je pense qu'on a besoin de rire
c'est dans la vie en général et dans
cette forme d'art parce que c'est du
théâtre élevé et il ya tellement de
fondeurs mis ensemble parce que c'est
vraiment des artistes de performance
mais aussi des designers de costumes des
mecs c'est comme c'est vraiment de la
fantaisie en fait la fantaisie puis
c'est que c'est pas juste les hommes qui
interprète des femmes des femmes qui à
présent des fois c'est des gens qui sont
différents de ceux ci toutes sortes de
choses qu'il ya vraiment plus que limite
là dedans lui même dans cette émission
l'a elle-même
ils ont brisé les stéréotypes qu'il ya
dedans dans ce monde a détruit tout
parce que c'est tout le monde qui peut
faire ça tout le monde peut se rhabiller
d'une manière qui est différent qui qui
qui nous soulève dans la fantaisie avec
les couleurs avec avec la performance
avec la musique avec l'humour c'est
vraiment quelque chose pour moi c'est la
position préférée et je me suis toujours
dire qu'ici si j'arrive à être un guest
jawad hajjar grèce
ça veut dire que ma carrière fonctionne
ça s'est passé ça s'est passé super
super magnifiquement qui a justement
connaît pas ce que c'était avant tout
tout les trucs les ladders excusez moi
cette célébration de la delà de la
différence
est ce que ça vous cherchez à vous
cherche pas votre vie personnelle
oui absolument parce que on est tous
différent justement que moi j'ai jamais
jamais vraiment je me suis jamais
vraiment identifié avec les normes à la
base même même entente dans ma vie à moi
j'sais pas c'est pas top 100 a gagné je
n'ai pas 100 % montréal et j'ai quand
même entre les deux ce qu'a déjà juste
ça c'est quelque chose je me suis dit ok
mais moi je suis dit que moi pourquoi je
dois être quelque chose qui est rentré
dans une boîte qui les gens me disent
qu'ils sont moi ou pas moi même même
dans les dents les autres et hayal la
catégorie normal les autres catégories
et tous même dans ceux là je sais pas
donc je me dis ok je suis juste moi
pourquoi me mettre à l'ebbo pourquoi me
dire ok je suis sage fait partie de
cette communauté est parti cette
communauté oui ok on a toutes les
différences donc pourquoi pas juste
exprimer qui ont qui nous sommes ce sont
nous limiter à l'épaule quoi que ce soit
en fait même tous hétéros pas été route
je trouve que salim est en fait parce
qu'on est des êtres beaucoup plus
infinie qui est juste se dire ok je suis
ça explique exactement on est vraiment
beaucoup plus que ça et c'est comme ça
que je vois la vie moi donc
donc pour moi c'est important gain est
aussi c'est important d'être moi même
d'une manière qui va inspirer d'autres
jeunes être même si tu sais aussi
surtout dans la culture aura pas ce que
c'est encore plus rigide disons que ça
va puis puis pour moi c'est important de
pouvoir inspirer les autres jeunes à
lever la tête et être qu'ils sont sans
voix a expliqué à personne est vraiment
marcher la tête haute et vraiment savoir
qu'ils sont
qui sont ils valent la peine d'exister
genre c'est tout c'est vraiment seul
message être ce qu'on est tout
simplement son chercheur à se définir ou
quoi que ce soit j'ai tout à l'heure
vous avez dit que on doit votre début de
votre carrière
il ya des gens qui vous disais que ça
valait pas le coup ils vont par le
choisir et vous avez continué quels
conseils pouvez vous donner aux jeunes
donc dans ce sens moi je dirais aux
jeunes que dans la vie quand fond et
quand il va les opportunités vont venir
et si tu aimes quelque chose continuer à
faire cette forme d'art pense pas
comment ça va se passer
celle pour l'amour de le faire pour la
joie que ça donne
continuer à créer continue à peu importe
que ce soit le sport avouera veut
vraiment continuer à se concentrer sur
ce qu'on aime et le faire et lettres est
vraiment juste de faire et la vie
bernier opportunités
tu vas rencontrer des gens et c'est
jamais ces camps et sait comment puisque
se concentrer sur le commencement ça
enlève ça enlève le focus sur vraiment
devenir meilleur dans son bain sauna au
basson
dans son talent et c'est un peu comme de
être prêt pour que quand l'opportunité
arrive tu es prêt tu es là tu es déjà en
train d'être qui tuait comprend donc moi
j'ai juste continué en forme et active
du continent continuent à conduire parce
que j'aime ça parce que c'est qui je
suis
puis en fait j'ai rien charge et j'ai
continué à faire la même chose que je
faisais quand elle avait dix ans c'est
la même chose qui ajuste évolué et
évoluent et c'est pas une plante c'est
la rose ça continue de grandir et un
jour l'opportunité arrive quelqu'un qui
est un qui a besoin d'une personne comme
toi de découvrir par vous et vous êtes
prêt à ce moment de vous en tant
qu'enfant immigrant es ce que vous avez
eu des défis particuliers que vous avez
senti que c'est vos défis sont un peu
différents de ceux des autres qui sont
dans la mode qui appartiennent à la
majorité
ouais c'est intéressant parce que j'ai
pas j'ai pas cette perspective j'ai
jamais il se laisser votre vécu tout ça
fait bourrer j'ai jamais j'ai jamais
réalisé que j'avais des des handicaps
disons genre parce que je ressemble à
quelque chose je viens mais quelque part
j'ai jamais si jamais vraiment réalisé
pas ça si c'est vraiment comment mes
parents m'ont indiqué n'ont jamais fait
sentir différent mais j'aurais vraiment
expliquer qu est-ce qu il était venu
mais c'était juste comme des cités où
j'ai vécu puis ça a pris du temps
commence à réaliser à wade et jacky qui
s'identifie un point où il se met dans
une vraiment 1,27 de penser qu' il ya
des gens qui te juste d'une manière dans
ce monde et qui tant qu'ils veulent dans
le détail opportunités c'est vraiment 27
puis quand tu penses comme ça lui sera
pas affectée mais si tu penses pas comme
ça du tout que ça c'est complètement
rien à voir avec qui tu es des
opportunités vont quand même venir une
vielle ils viennent ils viennent et
diane et ça m'a pas affecté parce que
parce que j'ai jamais pensé que j'étais
une minorité de comprends j'ai juste été
moi même j'ai fait mes choses et je
savais que j'allais réussir
point supposer qu'ils sont très
classiques mais j'aime bien la pause et
c'est quoi la réussite pour vous le
présentez récents comme question ok
c'est plein de choses mais j'ai vraiment
réalisé que la réussite pour moi c'est
d'abord en raid
une idée qui a l'air tellement
impossible est de la voir se créer une
idée à la réalité ça se passe et c'est
vraiment pour moi j'en la fortune parce
que j'ai tellement eu des rêves comme ça
surtout très spécifiques qui ont leur
impossible mais qui se sont passées et
des choses que j'ai dit aux gens je vais
être l'enjeu maintenant ça je vais
personnes ouais ok ok oui mais puis la
bourre
là tu vois ici les gens nous on le voit
mais moi j'ai la joie de vivre
cette progression de rêver rêver rêver à
prendre action parce que je suis inspiré
à voir où la réalité bleus bien ce que
j'ai rêvé pis là pour moi c'est un
succès puisse associer dans tous disent
quand est ce que est ce qu'un succès
financier si nice oui est ce que je suis
comme c'est drôle parce que les gens
perçoivent autre chose complètement de
la réalité je suis pas super rendu à une
place parce que tout tout tout mon
argent je suis plus ils ont travaillé du
tout là moi je continue et je continue
pour moi j'ai pas encore je suis pas
encore arrivé mais je pense que jamais
dans ce loin la joie de com de voir les
choses se réalisent et pis comme le fun
que c'est de vivre tout ça moi c'est ça
c'est vous et vous êtes sur une traque
qui semble loin quand même
comment écrivez je vous remercie
beaucoup jade je rappelle que vous venez
de lancer une chanson s'appelle éphémère
cette chanson elle est sur toutes les
plateformes spotify toutes les passions
que les jeunes connaissent et javon 340
mille abonnés sur instagram la supply
chain effet nous vous remercions
beaucoup pour votre participation des
six agences est vraiment gentil
j'apprécie tellement